Gulam Johnny Depp today Ryan Wright is
gonna be doing a reaction review to him
in the looking-glass
yeah I'm gonna be doing a reaction
review to Alice Through the Looking
Glass Alison Wonderland was one of those
billion-dollar hits that a lot of people
seem to not like it made a [ __ ] ton of
money so we got a sequel I hear Johnny
Depp's back and you're like a looking a
lot of the main cast is back actually
Alice returns to Adventureland or
whatever the fucked-up place is called
Underland
it's Underland alright guys let's watch
this [ __ ] Disney meaning no monetization
of this video has been gone too long
Alice there are matches which might
benefit from more tension friends can't
be neglected
[Music]
when the day becomes the night sky
becomes the sea when the clock strikes
heavy and there's no time for TV and in
our darkest hour before my final rhyme
come back home to Wonderland and turn
back the hands of time times he is in
danger
young lady you're so lucky kid not
people
[Music]
the letter
hello Alice
[Music]
I present you with a gift James Bobin
directed this something tells me I'm
gonna get a lot of crap for saying this
looking forward to that film I really
enjoyed dark fantasy you know I felt
like that was something that Alice in
Wonderland was actually holding back on
you know it was Tim Burton but I know he
was doing it for Disney so probably have
to make it a light more lighthearted
there was dark elements for sure but I
thought Tim burger would go even crazier
with the darkness this film looks like
they're gonna go a lot darker I'm not
familiar with the books I didn't read
them I haven't read a lot of books I
need to read more books but the effects
look great the sweeping spectacle shots
look great Sacha Baron Cohen totally
looks like Loki there must be some
contractual obligation here because
let's let's think about this for a
second Tim Burton he produced this film
he has recently split with Helena Bonham
Carter now after the split she is back
working with Tim Bergen Johnny Depp was
their mutual friend I mean this Johnny
Depp have to choose between who he's
really friends with at the end of the
day I'm hoping he goes with Tim Burton
he should go with Tim Burton maybe they
all can be friends doubt it
it's not the way the world works people
there's so much mixed opinions on Johnny
Depp when it comes to his portrayal of
Mad Hatter I personally I don't think
it's his most unique performance I
really enjoy watching him though I
thought he's the best part of Alice in
Wonderland and I'm excited to see him
return to the character again it's kind
of cool that he's really in both
audiences some people might feel like oh
he just did Black Mass I thought he was
a serious actor again now he's going
back to being the Mad Hatter I think
it's kind of cool because he does have
like a family audience base ever since
Pirates of the Caribbean and stuff and
now you know he's trying to satisfy the
adult base too with things such as Black
Mass and I'm hoping he continues a
balance of doing his fun kind of films
and also doing his serious films
I feel like this film could be funnier
this is the first trailer so they don't
really show us the actual personality of
the film that you're showing us the dark
tone and adventure that's gonna have to
happen this director directed a lot of
the Ali G show he directed a lot of the
episodes of flight of the conchords he
directed the Muppets movies the the
recent ones and I didn't see him up its
most Warner but what I liked about the
first Muppets was it was a family film
but you could tell a lot of adults
really enjoyed it too so I feel like he
can provide that same thing where he
provides a movie that the whole family
can really enjoy not just kids hopefully
I mean this is gonna be his biggest film
he's ever done so it's a challenge and
you know I'm sure it's different from
when you're really working hardcore for
a studio on such a major picture I'm
hoping they let him have his creative
freedom to actually make this script a
lot more humorous and the way how he
likes to do it so yeah I'm gonna give it
a shot I'm gonna give it a shot anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today by clicking this button
and become a rejecter let's get less and
less cool as time goes on
Dehlia scene hey guys my name is Yasiin
and i've been a fan since you were at
20,000 subs and i'm really glad to see
how much you've grown
I find the opinion from everyone from
Ryan to brandy Veronica Lauren and
everyone else really interesting and fun
at the same time as I do movie and album
reviews on my Instagram della Yassin so
I hope you do more movie reviews Ryan PS
I have clinical depression maybe you can
use that for the shower I love y'all
what you want me to make funnier
clinical depression not gonna make fun
of your clinical depression I'm
diagnosed with Chloe I'm diagnosed with
PTSD I didn't go to the war or something
but I have other reasons why that's
sincere I know I sound like I'm being
sarcastic but I'm really diagnosed with
that yes I can make fun of the fact that
you want attention for your depression
that's really just a call for help
you know like fact that you're saying
that and then how we make you feel
better like that's awesome that we do
that but dude if you're really depressed
I hope you see like a
councillor means they have clinical
depression so I'm assuming you've been
diagnosed but I hope you stay consistent
and some type of therapy or group
counseling or even like getting involved
in something that just makes me feel
really good and allows you to learn
about yourself anything like that you
know like I recommend personal
development personal development I
listen to a lot of audio one of the main
guys elicits is a guy named Jim Rohn you
should really check his [ __ ] out Jay I
am ROH and there's a lot of this stuff
on YouTube I like Les Brown a lot John
see Maxwell is pretty cool when you
learn about leadership also pornhub.com
you can jerk off a lot whenever you're
down just jerk off you might develop a
sexual addiction you know you might
develop a porn addiction however it is
the best kind of addiction do I feel
ashamed of myself for being this into
porn
yeah thanks dela